[Music]
[Applause]
it's the final boss fight i'm going to
get him this time
charging my laser
i got him legendary loot
i didn't uh
see you all there
since i was young my granny has always
been telling me to never sit too close
to the tv or the computer or else my
eyes will go square as well as you are
what you eat but you are also what you
play on the computer and perhaps most
puzzling of all darling how do i google
something again
in fact the reason why i decided to do
this talk in the first place was because
i'd always hear this negativity around
the media about video games this person
killed someone and did something violent
because they played a video game
i really didn't want any of this
negativity to be true so i decided to do
a bit of research
one of the first studies i looked at was
short but positive and it showed that
playing portal 2 which is a very very
popular puzzle game improves spatial
skills problem solving and persistence
more than the supposed brain trainer
lumosity which is a browser-based brain
trainer
77 undergraduates sat a test and then
played eight hours of either portal 2 or
limosti
afterwards they set the same test again
and the results were pretty astounding
the portal 2 players had improved their
spatial skills problem solving and
persistence by over 80 percent when
compared to the lumosity players
now this sounded pretty good but it gets
even better
this study is carried out by jeffery
snodgrass
who by the way has the best name in
science ever and i know a lot of good
guys in science like the best
and in this study he examines different
types of video gaming experiences and
their effects on players lives including
their self-reported stress levels life
satisfaction and happiness
in his study dr snodgrass and his team
examined the popular online game world
of warcraft which currently has around
5.6 million players worldwide in this
game players develop virtual avatars and
complete tasks in cooperation with other
players
now the complex and highly interactive
nature of this type of game can often
lead players to feel as if they're in
some important sense separate from the
world outside of the game these types of
video games are commonly known as mmo
rpgs or massively multiplayer online
role-playing games
now dr snodgrass and his research team
noticed that when players became very
very involved when playing world of
warcraft for a short to medium period of
time after they finished play they
reported high levels of stress relief
and tension relief however dr snudgrass
and his team also noted that if a player
played world of warcraft became very
immersed and then played for a longer
period of time they actually reported
less stress relief or even increases in
stress
so dr sudgrass and his team noticed this
phenomenon happening happening so often
they labeled it as an immersive
experience and when a player becomes
deeply immersed in a game like world of
warcraft or any other game for that
matter
they can often lead players to feel as
if they're in so involved with their
character
that they forget the world outside of
the game and can report positive
and negative stress relief and tension
relief or gain depending on how long
they play for
so
quick little recap some video games can
improve various skills like spatial
skills problem solving and persistence
and some can put you into a trance-like
state that alleviates stress and tension
in small to medium doses however some of
the negative effects that video games
can and do in jews certainly
disheartened me when i was doing my
search
this study
features 172 high school students each
playing a violent video game such as gta
or grand theft auto or a non-violent
video game such as 3d mini golf or
pinball
they played this game for 35 minutes and
were told that they could snack from a
roll of m ms as they played however they
were warned that eating too many of them
was bad for their health
their level of self-control was measured
by whether they just couldn't resist
grabbing a fistful of those sweet little
chocolate goodness pellets ramming them
straight down their throat or whether
they did the impossible and only ate two
or three at a time
it shocks me just thinking about it and
i honestly believe those people should
have movies based on them
after finishing play gamers had to
answer some questions on a one-to-seven
scale completely agreed to completely
disagree participants answered questions
like insulting a classmate is okay
because physically hurting them is far
far worse
these types of questions are designed to
measure something called moral
disengagement or in layman's terms
getting people to think of their
behavior in relative terms
this experiment concluded with a test
that was designed to measure aggression
players took part in a competitive
reaction task
so many fancy words in this study
or a small game where the winner of each
round was allowed to blast the loser
with some loud and very unpleasant noise
their level of aggression was measured
by how long and how loud the winners
played this sound
now the results were probably what you
would expect but surprisingly consistent
across the board the people who played
the violent video game gta grand theft
auto reported higher levels of
aggression more disengagement and less
self-control than the people who played
the non-violent video game 3d mini golf
or pinball who i will state again at an
impossibly small number of m m's like
less than a kilogram how is that even
possible
and this last study proves that when the
media claims that playing video games
leads to violence as it does so often
the claims themselves actually lead to
violence bear with me a second
dr mario vance conducted a seven year
long study that measured the levels of
aggression in more than one thousand
volunteers from gaming communities
across the world
and the results showed that increases in
overall aggression and violent
tendencies started when participants
viewed a news or media story that
claimed with usually no evidence that
playing video games caused you to become
an irrevocably violent murderer
dr mario vance has stated before that
the mainstream media has never liked
video games but it's getting a bit silly
now because whenever someone does a
violent thing and it turns out they have
played video games before in the past
even if it was legend of zelda as a kid
they are obviously a murderer and should
never be touched or gone now
so from these various studies i tried to
come to a definite conclusion video
games are good for you or video games
are bad for you and then it hit me the
problem is that people are looking for
this definite yes or no answer when
there isn't one
video games alone don't cause people to
become more violent and do violent
things but they also don't cause you to
become more smarter
but then again these days when we have
such immersive and wonderful devices
like the oculus rift which is a virtual
reality headset that places a screen
directly in front of your eyes and
allows you to be inside and control the
character
you have to wonder what the effects of
puzzle and violent video games like
portal 2 or grand theft auto will be
when we're killing people in such great
levels of emotion but solving puzzles in
that level of immersion too you have to
wonder if humanity will just kind of
desensitize ourselves even more to this
kind of violence or whether we will just
become much much more clever people
all speculation aside the video games
are a truly wondrous invention they can
transport us to different more vibrant
worlds let us do things that we would
otherwise dream is impossible and are
arguably the single greatest invokers of
emotion as we become the people who can
make friendships get betrayed go on
killing sprees solve puzzles uncover
ancient artifacts and walk away from a
really impressive explosion wearing
awesome looking sunglasses in slow
motion
but when you're playing video games
there are three super important things
that you have to remember one have fun
two play in moderation and three get
that final boss thank you
you